[Applause]
[Music]
what's your favorite thing to do in
video games solve murders shoot enemy
soldiers fly spaceships well you'll get
to do all of those things this week
unfortunately it's not all from the same
game but if that game ever does exist
make sure you're subscribed to new
releases and you'll be the first to know
let's get to it if you've missed out on
the dangan ronpa games because they only
came to vita and steam then you're in
luck danganronpa one to reload brings
the first two games trigger happy havoc
and goodbye despair over to the ps4
finally console owners will get to
experience the magic of figuring out
which of your classmates murdered each
other okay so magic probably isn't the
right word there but in any case that's
launching on Tuesday March 14th and if
you're up for some dangan ronpa then
you'll probably be interested in some
persona 5 too so head over to gamespot
for over 10 minutes of English gameplay
do you find yourself wishing for a
sequel to 2014 sticks master of shadows
well here comes shards of darkness the
stealthy orc can still turn invisible
and clone himself but this time his
mission is to infiltrate the elven city
of Coron guard luckily he won't have to
do it alone shards of Darkness lets you
take control of one of stix's clones to
play cooperatively the stealthy sequel
slips on the ps4 xbox one and pc on the
fourteenth the middle of March seems
like a great time to revisit World War
one and it's also in battlefield ones
they shall not pass dlc launches for you
lucky premium members this expansion
adds the French army along with four new
maps for done Heights Fort de Vaux seuss
all and rupture it also adds the new
front lines game mode which requires
your armies to push objectives one flag
at a time and of course that's all on
top of a new behemoth new guns and the
new trench Raider elite class they shall
not pass launches on the 14th for
premium members and the rest of us will
have to wait until the end of the
let's move out of the war-torn past and
look toward the future with Star Trek
bridge crew if you've ever wanted to
pilot a Starfleet ship now you can and
it looks like a lot of fun in VR the
crew of the USS ages is tasked with
finding a new home world for the Vulcans
and this particular mission will take
you to the trench a dangerous Klingon
occupied region of space up to four
players can put on headsets and get the
job done taking on the roles of Captain
tactical officer engineer and helm
officer you can strap in with psv our
oculus rift or HTC vive on the 14th
speaking of co-op games let's talk about
death squared this puzzle platformer
lets up to four players take control of
cute little robots to reach their
special colored squares but of course
getting there isn't too easy there are
plenty of spikes and laser beams in your
way you can take on these levels alone
with a friend or by yourself but in
control of two robots on one controller
and don't forget those party challenges
designed for a full four robots quad
death squared comes to ps4 xbox one and
pc on the fourteenth and those are the
big games will be playing this week as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back with more games
next week
[Music]